and there's quite a few I've never
played so hopefully I get a bracket
where I play nobody before and welcome
back everyone this is the Tekken World
Tour Finals we are in Group A coming up
next we got shadow versus neuroma and
look man they stay talking they stay
talking mess about this dude talk about
how sleep he looks on a danceOn
he looked lied awake against me that
person right but going up against one of
Japan's finest right again a little bit
more inconsistent this year than when we
were used to put there was a period in
time I think last year an even here from
Orton he was the most consistent player
in Japan it was super weird right we saw
how like powerful he was the entire and
then finals came around it
Oh what happened to neuroma you know
where to go so here he is now 2019
finals what a neuroma okay now we're
gonna get dragging on what character we
gonna get that's the other thing too man
a lot of uncertainty around that he's
lost confidence in jack it feels like
which is the character that he came to
international prominence with but he
went up drag against Joe shadow runnings
of oh I like the way she moved ripka you
ain't the only one jaw versus of being a
Howard estate and dragging off someone
strong and out this season
yeah I'm really not surprised to see him
go with this pick but Jack's also
stronger too you know let's see what
happens though neuroma versus shadow
Japan vs. USA
I know shad was talking about you know I
like playing players I've never played
before there's a lot of them though all
of them might be one of them maybe on
Howard a stay tuned both these
characters have really good movement
even but then the big thing is all in
close quarters like this we can get
control of the wall and actually has
Safina gets tracking up might be really
saw it because the size depth is
try to help him out chatter hold on
Mantha stance right under the spot I'm
under you and that's what you got to
beware of - right
low profile an axe especially out of
stances Wow beautiful sight - right get
the downpour - here comes in the Roman
now all the way not quite misses the
last is there and now shadow with range
maybe in the corner though running - to
the wall no running - the Russian
assault pressure pills it's still up you
shadow out and open then yo picks it up
off the side because the wall is there
nicely done shadow get in the first
round here and he is the present Oh God
the county had razor no you forgot about
it
Finn the down - all day little doll the
back of those on the late oh my goodness
grapevine
yeah that's doing a lot of it he's doing
a lot of stands transitions to not only
getting a lot of return on okay that's
the first big head rear mm-hmm launched
off the low push to the wall I can't
believe you went for it in the back
though no baby he's been ducking on
those pins perfectly raised our favor
advantage
I check get her out of stance Oh Romo
with a raise drive me over closing out
in mid range we're out to be game one
here Howard a stain again you can see
coming into play they're both just in
each other's growth via tires on yeah
Lots down floors who gets caught at the
counter and walls right there as well I
like that shadow sticky to sit really
close to him on the offensive to not
really giving him enough space if they
were trying to I get trying to get a
Russian assault right try to build off
some prey pressure see how solid defense
there he hasn't really tried to sidestep
about 22
[Music]
aah splat boner over here back home to
put the pressure bring the bandage there
off the jabs page have more skin plus it
doesn't off spots ghosts at that time oh
my god
please at your house can always emblem
winds out shadow threatening to take
this first game against the Roman yo too
slow balls one game let's go let's say
first Japan here mm-hmm
pick it up down yeah hey you know where
we going right there the shadow in
control right now
trying to close out the first game wall
splats up from neuroma shadow stick on
the ground knocking to tech roll down to
float firm third and surprise wo that
else in accident doesn't work out we're
almost got him cornered here go for the
high note duck from shadow a soul run
the night one more time look at the
patients from shadow solid play shadow
get it the first thing crawling on out
of here okay what it came to
also my question for no Roma are you
content to keep that drag are you gonna
go to be one of your other characters
that's a hard question or do you believe
in drag this change on stage wait what
does he go I haven't really seen a lot
of Jack versus Athena doesn't look like
he's even thinking about it though I was
curious about jack hammer or select
mantis yeah yeah she goes underneath the
rock of course you have being able to
play the game around one side step left
in them thread up of course down ports
you to be able to counter that maybe I
don't know but cueing it on drag
regardless and he's locked in at this
point yeah I don't think that he really
played that necessarily bad I think he
said he's just more shadow being very
patient picking his moments and there
wasn't anything those like huge
character and experience that I saw
there yeah from neuroma just just good
cause from shadowing scramble situations
and just was able to just take control
his guard went out too that's true so
here we go though game number two we're
almost switching the stage up going the
Mishima dojo a little bit more space
this time and they didn't break a wall
yeah we played we stated the same score
in the entire time
hose it out for twitch that would happen
oh you still got the Jester hat yeah
the morning he's a clown man anybody
always running the Jester hangout here
we go
see they start this one out the Roman
trying to again establish this mid-range
poke game right a little more space to
work with dogs them stretchy limbs
though yeah it's back in electric castle
where shadow first started using this
beam internment I think and yeah at the
time it seemed like always he's messed
out another character he's trying it out
but he really believed in the character
here we're seeing it in the finals now
and especially in the months leading up
to the spinal - right he's had some
really good performances with it
putting it down to some more shadow the
one yet working his jabs going in a
scarecrow
the Romans eating a lot of hits here to
get most and transitions really working
out for shadow yeah I'm gonna roll here
I'm stuck doing a lot more down to
normal wedding with the punished get off
the drive in the mid strike after that
drive and walk every time a salt cream
advantages all right in the role again
in the first round here
and that's thing a lot of time you'll
seem to roll with you use been trying to
catch shadow off-guard by like go off
like the low fairy timing or like
thinking like delaying its time when
he's down for two to get out deductive
low for himself but he hasn't really
been hit him low a lot was shot just and
guarding all day again and now Bork down
to makes again a lot more with this
downpour won this round
wow the other sides are sliced up is so
big you called it from the knife out oh
that's the date of your shadows like
y'all I know I play you're gonna go long
go I'm gonna question you but eventually
I'm gonna pull it out and I need it slow
strike spider up for shadow and that's
not that's another on defense against
this character to write most of those
lows are counter hit launchers you're
okay to just take the poke sometimes but
then when they add up like that right
you cost you around very easily midst
right there I love and you went for the
jab and that's the right thing to do and
that's cotton situation keep the jab
eyes at watch continue your combo
mixing up his pressure with his jabs in
the doubtful ones knife is sealed we're
gonna maybe close out the round with it
doesn't wanna go yet you're trying to
hold that mid-range not ready for ya cuz
it the PC get hit by that rage drive a
boys at this time now shadows still
trying to work his way back in this
round and he's kind of going it goes
with a big load this time to roll his
defense odd point holds onto it I like a
little slice of it from Manorama yeah
put it down - all day right now the
shadow dorms locus and the lone pair Eve
nice Hey whoa that's big return for that
exchange
oh girl she's got those moves they get
it from the back oh my god final round
at that point for shadow right now
underneath the getting up more for now
working out oh she can't blow she can't
love rip she getting real low down there
look for the low
okay I'll have to crush once again and
the role of men is every second to go
final game rate drive spent shot has got
a pic so can he make it crazy come back
here but this time content to just hold
guard adjust and go to stand off these
smart stuff smart stuff neuroma gonna
tie it up here one apiece and now
shadows got that thought right it's like
do I stick it out with Safina here do I
bring out the big boy the Claudia on one
Claudio in Game three
I don't know man I piss think strap
worked out for all song what anyone yeah
but I feel like she has the kind of
player who he sticks to his guns when he
picks a character for the beginning and
I haven't really seen him pick a
character switching a set but we'll see
all right final game in coming here what
aren't gonna be the change then we saw a
lot more of two loads coming out in Rome
in the last game lot more the down two's
shadow let him happen then finally crush
it a couple times but overall I feel
like we're almost starting to get a
little bit of control here I feel like
that's been the main interaction we've
been watching for in this in this
matchup is who can who's gonna be
insistent on their lows who's gonna
crush it in return and then the back and
forth from there right right and of
course you know shadow you know he has
it but really using the size of his
bunch but we saw what with Norman gave
to the game one I expect to see even
more of it here in Game three
and yes I step inside walking got to get
clean around the other side that one
rushing us all the temperature oh yeah
we're gonna see more of that for sure I
bet here's old man this time teleport
[ __ ] connect I think the world was
delaying deal for for a little bit so
old reports that gets our out of
Manchester Wow right underneath around
to the right side advances super cancel
in the guard
surprise the mid hey just take those
down hits the Roman go with proposition
here back to the wall [ __ ] off the drive
go slow that time close first round here
that's the first low post race driver Oh
God
Oh in the downpour to close it out from
the Roma in the mid range yeah he's been
doing that a few times now to close out
the rounds right you got expect a big
mix-up or maybe I won't be that's the
don't mix that mix up right on the hit
knife run it again
low parry from shadow though yeah he's
still young man he's got reactions more
knife stage here books on a mantis
adding up bring it down to the drive
worst waste going know which stuff is
out
and shadow now content just yet wait
where's our holy boy if any wonderful I
can't believe the Roman advanced our man
Spartan runs up down court he doesn't
want to leave the page later like let
the time become a factor he's gonna
close out now at set point for neuroma
really adjusting to the subpoena pick
get the block there there's the punish
and it's not looking good for shadow
right now all four point five is mark
again and some odd well with the back -
paying off there but no punish on it
senior pressure now now shadow turn to
the wall in no Roma over shadow to one
they see big breath released they're
from neuroma that was not an easy one
but he really pulled it back together
there maybe this will be the year that
we've seen a robo really step up in the
final in that shadow two really good
sets for him back to back but he's lost
both ones although two one set count
right that's true if it comes down to
that we how many we could be then we see
that play out in an awkward way maybe
four so for another player somebody who
doesn't control their own destiny right
right so when you look at the standings
overall of course shadow has two losses
but he's got those games and now the
matches he has left though are giving
Arslan - and I believe old sod so you
know if he beat them he's still in
content you despite having these two
losses we'll see how this shakes down
man this is a starting to get dicey
already here oh yeah this is gonna be
good man and coming up next we get the
Korea vs. Korea match we get knee versus
old sod generations may examine it was
going to see mm-hmm rocks dragons vs.
fate
especially with a lot of the
conversation that we've been seeing talk
about the Korean community in the past
couple months right right there's a lot
of discussion about what lohi represents
him what all some represents compared to
what you know did me and JD see our
generation representing and I mean this
do you get to see it culminate on this
brawl final stage here in 2019 technolon
yeah to me they're like three
generations I feel like knees like
generation before jtr yeah yeah then
it's like the JDC are st. generation and
then after that it's the the Ulsan
generation and we talked to all sign
interview before the finals went off
does anybody have to say okay cause I'm
me only say I call my guys in there
Casa de niro so Marco Marra come on
today yo kita mone Kumar Chandra Babu Oh
Hans Orihime Inoue Takehiko see my
linaanddame Abu curry to go do we have
another jig on it yeah he wished our and
I think I'll play Mira how you feel
about that room whoever happy
I just want away I respect that hell
yeah and he and yo he put his money
where his mouth was and then they said
what block you want give me that one I
won but he made the first call right now
we're off the bat and he got the W right
so now he's trying to continue both
these guys both have wins in this group
so far Jesus I'm have a loss yet
someone's going home with loitering out
and this D Fox pic coming out of me here
this is something we've seen a lot out
of him this year he's Steve Fox have
been extremely strong along with his
policies I think those apply the
character some use the most especially
up against Ulsan it feels like he always
keeps up he's ready to cue up Steve
everytime in this matchup that's a good
point actually I think I think that's
very true old song Kazumi no surprise
you know pop pick this time you don't
wear a match I guess what I want to see
is in these interactions that rains you
arrange one like this
how old sons able to deal with again
dumb pressure than a porch down pour
water down for one the jabs and of
course credit downpour to run the thread
up back was probably really good counter
pick for a kazoo be think about it that
way because a lot for tools of to keep
her up close there and that's exactly
what Steve wants it to be he's like yeah
come here can we get some downpour lots
of the jabs let me have his back we'll
see if it finds a partner magic though
man he's been on point of those today
can you meet the wall you with the tiger
yes they were all crazy three never
asked that question
Oh thought get in the first one
oh I'll try to seal that stuff seem
dashing turn away your line try to step
running to the wall here looking for the
magic do you recognize it it hitting the
brakes no duck there the walk before hot
me from old thought I don't know where
that game that was crazy
tiger he's in the driver's seat this
first game right now this is top it's
old side of me we've mentioned he's been
a little lackluster the second half of
the year but here he is he's coming into
this final with very very high level of
focus man that's people you think it's
always the place you don't expect new
well when I'm stepping up to the plate
right the people you expect to win the
finals have not wanna find in the last
couple years down by the last of last
points
Lyons what's a knockdown and where I'll
take your look here
and the town to checks for me in chapter
VIII line Wow could break in the throw
slowpokes - blocks range for bulk now
you knew it was common phrase drive out
of nowhere
Ulsan three-round Street you know I'm
starting to think it's just nice
switching characters not stopping as I
would kick right now how do I play skate
the first game our next game I got him
I mean it's something that we talked a
little bit about this year - right
that's kind of something you know this
the way this game is you can pick up a
lot of characters you really can't play
that at highest level it comes only you
know something only very few players can
pull off right this is like finals level
you don't hit at what point does it hurt
you you know
exactly Swiss up Bryan early now we've
got to be with Steve here and boat says
he's lost the first game I expected that
this game will be much more competitive
the first game
show the wall pup with one through huge
life with the advantage right now Forney
yeah that instant rematch you right like
like all right yeah you got first one to
nine oh what's up he takes some time to
write it's his download speed yeah
you know Korean internet real place to
it's too fast yeah it's slow but nope a
clock you know who's that you use the
original roll back that goes good down
jab there from hold on one to us on no
big swings either right just working jab
pressure down for one Rolling Thunder
that stuff that's to go to bread butter
right there hmm
and he's moving so Chris before that
down Ford one a second ago
alright the forward to be finds its mark
will son's been appointed placing those
Oh beautiful statue down three Ulsan
ties it up the round count here
you trying to duck in there I'll eat the
jabs or something it doesn't find it
that time down but you know counter him
get on some carts you right
it's very twitchy right a lot alike it
feels like he's always trying to just
buffer fuzzies and just these micro
steps as well the right decision in so
many places recognize what he's about to
do this time gets him probably stuck in
a movement she got a pic okay oh man she
got a big old cat crazy cat lady and she
went wrong well he had perfect timing on
there caught him - [ __ ] bullseye
still at the perfect block the chance
here and you want to stop going to step
in and hook ready with the garden the
doc in the punish holes for that point
crazy crazy
threading the - Oh neat they're here
tough to counter itself all the way to
the wall he's stepping on the gas and
you know we at tile and we do those
massages real I'm here hey Wildman cop
with a waltz and one to Carter Duncan
though I'll ban the walls in the way
though so deep of meat doesn't eat the
Ray Drive this time
[Music]
now with that banished now at the wall
that Wroclaw - wasn't enough too far for
the wall the walls on the Jamz off the
duct final round game - that's liquor
juice no counter - no [ __ ] no hit even
very passive oh my god that was 15
seconds of just waiting for that one
opening and look at the return for - 60
% give me the wall while standing for 4
from all side good here comes the
ScrewAttack trying to find the wall
Tigers gonna help out a little bit run
into with the pressure
oh the mix-up these are a deal and the
rain dried and that should be the game
he ties it up one apiece man when he hit
that raised a bull's eye popped out if
you like oh damn it the real light hits
done it happen another thing another
game 3 scenario here and all side you
were able to pull it was able to get it
down again some Arsenal - can you
imagine what that does for this group if
he's able to go out on top on the right
oh my gosh that's so true
because that means that the nyantsen
hash match is gonna matter and so much
yeah
that could potentially determine who
action makes it out of this yeah because
there would be the second place position
potentially it will some get the winner
over knee that's we're talking about
going to an infinite stage to old man oh
yeah yeah so far thought was in for the
stage but really I feel like the walls
were helping him out a ton yeah I mean
it was just like huge damage potential
friendlies and I thought he was able to
actually take more advantage of the
pressure and a lot of those situations -
I agree completely off you launch it
returns over bolts on the start off this
round one here oh wait oh that thing's
blockable bro girl all right the blue
thump Sonic Drive here's the confrim
he's got a pick so it's enough it's
enough down let him know sir the back -
full stop perfectly time and then you
get the first one he's only attempted to
down back three twice so far all son has
had the perfect answer both times just
perfect just reason you just lose yeah
he's new 100% first time he just
immediately ducked it this time - back -
all point man nice pick you watch those
counter he needs those counters right
now splash bucks knockdown damage here
comes down for - no I'm gonna tie my own
dumb magic stuff not even on help but in
the enrage
the out about all that rayful pull the
immediately spent is that the all man
the jab got one more - it's enough
damage one of the whole strong ten
favored parts in the game actually makes
sense thanks applause the box are after
all running - in close range like this
it's not just diving in
oh he puts through the cab I think she
got a magic for to you and me on fire
right now well sounds got a rage
Wildman comma for the block from far
away and now with his set point for neat
just like that it was all looking old so
on a second ago that download PDF a
Korean internet name don't mess with it
touch low parry in return no I run this
damn Internet bro these lows this whole
round is just n lows from balls on it's
time here comes the rage you know what's
gonna happen
oh he's not gonna let happen final final
round he says not burst of me huge
implications in this round
yet for the entire groups walls dead
appropriate card coming in why mixup
also I'm looking good right now
[Music]
oh yeah oh he could have sonic bang or
something didn't do anything meet - up
jab for the whip punish trade oh god
he's looking for that man wanted oh oh
duck yo knees got great oh he's gotta
make us come back the old-fashioned way
oh you know what he's looking for walk
back what could do it here with the mix
of Aperta specially 15 seconds on the
clock Bulls like to give the jail break
on the throw doesn't get them back with
just a regular that's up 10 seconds to
go meet with the decorator what would
you get up here five seconds on the
clock Oh takes it over me and takes the
lead in this group Wow
yo old side be getting to play today
when you step up and say put me in the
doghouse I'm ready to swim man and then
he cook right he just went through me
and all that completed check that
changes our outlook on this group a
right now but you said it could very
well come down in neighbours arson - not
particularly to fight but they even make
it out a group stage that's crazy
this group is still crazy though because
he's lucky he's not played in a robe up
and shadow these are still players who
can beat him you know like it's not a
free batter but even though it seems
like he's in the drive she don't wanna
burn alright the robe was undefeated in
this group - oh my god in the fact that
it just came down you know so badly also
on the entire time fishing for the magic
where he wanted it so badly and you knew
me camping out at that perfect spot that
gets hurt fishing for the county back
when he wanted so bad oh my gosh those
back that's the clutch back to ashes at
the end he recognized and he had it -
Tiffany try to force the mix-up right
but you didn't have to raise him where
he had spent the race drive so that
makes up between the down back three and
the rage that was already gone but here
we have returning to the stage we got
our sling ash gonna be going up against
Japan's
neuroma course games don't roam again
Kyushu vs. Pakistan here Oh
oh this is crazy
marcin - already has a loss here in this
group you know this is kind of storyline
from last year's final right When in
Rome keep on he got beat up in the group
stage and we're like it was we were all
looking at like neuromas could do really
well to tournament what did that happen
here - Arslan act from neuroma that
would be crazy but we did speak with
Arslan before show as well let's go
ahead and give it a listen I want you
clear and Beach oh honey
there are a lot of people who is
complaining about Akuma but this time I
practiced really hard against Akuma so I
want to meet him yeah arson as we hear
you man you want to go up against Takumi
you got to get there first
mm-hmm it's gonna be a lot better I
don't think he has any Cooper's in this
group no no you gotta get out this group
first before you even get that chance
and standing right in front of you right
here right now you got no Roma and this
is not I'm curious about the character
selection is it that's worth it
especially for both of these players
right on both sides see you they queue
up yeah I see Kazumi from arson all day
and I'm completely wrong but no Roma no
roma lives in the same places Chickering
he knows this matchup just as well as
anybody else interesting choice for
Martha I mean cuz we didn't work out for
today you know I don't know how he's
feeling with it but right now going to
the keys Howard we get sook stage Roma
gets home-court advantage for his
character might be in the cards man game
this is a definitely matchup that he has
experience with like we were saying but
arson ash you got to remember the sets
that he's run especially recently right
and his geese no slouch at all he'll
know his keys is great
you know I'm already with the
interruptions here just down for one in
jobs right back - fishing with me and
trade in favor of neuroma rush the salts
mustering to the wall was that home
trying to get a wall that there's a find
it and the Roma chopping away he good
free to do it again you know it the
rhythm that he established you ready
establish controlling that ring zero
like that then you saw him start back -
wait for a will chop you up mid chop you
up low after that good mix from the Roma
- guard as well beautiful low attack -
Lopez something I've seen a lot of use
in the last two days ax a lot of players
we prepare for that now that brother can
still make you bleed in the wall Nikki
still a very strong character this just
changes meter basically that's placed
with the big change all right buddy
if you take your time with the character
build that that meter like peco's does
and then use it though yeah you make
sure you get that hit you get some
damage out of it or even burn it for
pressure you know that's a part of the
you have options with it yeah that was a
great block from there over here at that
believe that that should eat oh my god
he's bringing this back right now
he's got reigns - oh my god no press
Monroeville bringing it back with rage
there didn't even need a radio I didn't
either a jar just give me an extra
damage back greet you from Arslan now
you know just be content to just hold
guard get out of Dodge slowly circle
around the little puss rings and push
ash towards the wall stepping with him
to realize wow that was a sick with
punisher over on point today arsons
trapped right now don't jump for you
what you think this is can go up oh my
gosh left trying to realign hold that
wall positioning still Roma right now in
rage confirm our split not down yet you
should be able to build apart by the end
of this round as well yeah that meters
so important for ease now that meter
management these place close ranges jab
down for one pressure the lows from the
Roma started to come out now mm-hmm he's
been using them a ton of his set ducked
down the third hit and artha did burn
the meter that actually too
down for no counter it very very
insistent on that throw hmm yeah yeah
let's prepare to just break every time
there are almost defense holding up your
time winding down tap down to dodge up
and close it out can Roma make another
rage come back all the trade this time
final round game one
Mars has got the meter he's gonna have
to the last right scenario burn one
instant in him
yeah the wall - 45 % willing to go
double just for the extra damage boosts
here in arson hasn't got for any
counters yeah aroma still with Jerry
Jack's spec but Roman out oh boy gonna
pick it up yet the air that's a big big
game-changer a huge and still gets the
wall - bridge though both of them with
ring a picture of it down to again art
that clutching and out bringing it all
the way back there man that was back and
forth but that down to you know he's
going to it so many times the norm was
letting for the most part yeah but that
I finally just enough damage to get the
job done
oof yeah this is no robot mistake that
yeah yes then rematch it was the kana it
was the kind of game the back-and-forth
you can't feel too bad about that right
like the wrist just couple scramble
situations that just went arson ashes
way for the most part pretty one played
on both sides yeah you know art
suspending all that meter and nor oh but
still sticking to the same game plan to
right mmm-hmm hanging out range one give
them wings easy roll my turn
we're punished yeah those micro steps
laughing but it's been without giving up
too many hits on is he still holding his
guard pretty well oh boy caught up
inside closes up with no meter here not
too much damn for neuroma
but he comes every time here to crush
the low ends the rage art what la and
the hell to hurry you gonna do take you
all with some answers for that one
what just happened but again the low
crutches are paying off your for our
slit wall care is easy here on the stage
he's got a bar already saved up I'm
trying to swing his way off this wall
three no confirm counted hit night oh
and stop on you Norma gets - car -
nothing with the meter behind him
there's no off the wall that one saved
with Max what activated spends his blue
stuff tonight and arson a slowly slowly
taking control of the game away find
everything there almost Alinea just it
was so close every round you back work
with a look at the low prairie arts on
that trying to get a read under all the
time and crap Roma has use that down to
quite a bit in the set natural pressure
the keys has opens up for some of those
lows at close range like that counter it
yeah I'm for gonna pick it up
and she wins on it that's the huge drop
and Rome can make this comeback
countertop or the one again stop jacking
off sorry guess the way no an artist I
watch this jump back I'm ready for it
setpoint Arslan Nationale and are some
first of all meets the Whittier but if
after you win it's just gonna tie in the
rope with the set overall but it's not
done just yet
put a big lead for arson counter and get
a blow all weekend long weekends on all
day yesterday and from side to side take
you for a ride the Roman out back three
in the to swing with the meter behind it
pocket punished not the wall it's weird
walk back guilty closes it out anyway
final round game to still set point for
Arslan ass here
[Music]
the one 1/2 in returning he's down for
once these chaps from arson ass right
now
homo right back at you very cautious
right now don't touch is now more brave
with the offense look at the sidewalk to
the back oh my god that was a huge whip
arson get him a campaign spend all the
park rage mode now prefer normal
pressure and decide Stephanie is gonna
get it done Arslan ass getting the
victory tuna 0 over neuroma Manny had
that sidewalk to the back yet so it's
good pressure afterward but then just
that was unfortunate with yeah and of
course he gets a character like yeast
with meaner especially on the stage like
that he didn't even get the wall didn't
even needed no it didn't nobody I mean
he's the damage now even without wall
yeah great I think the new of course
Nietzsche runs on the end that on
infinite stages now he is damage is
consistent regardless l Arthur - making
it happen with the geese Howard pick
here didn't need the Kazumi I wonder if
that's just a character backs but he
prefers possibly okay could be yeah
right we'll find out later I guess
mmm-hmm one man that now that means no
Roma down two games in this group is
that right baby yet first when he got
first we could shadow can shadow he won
the first end and now he's lost yet so
it's one of those oh he's 101 so he's
not out of it and that means he's
actually tied with with arson - yes
awesome - Nina Rome all 101 in this
group that is crazy
that's ridiculous pulse out up here with
the two and oh and he took out knee and
are slit and now you're going up again
another generation battle right mm-hm
yeah the young is the comin at it yeah
we're gonna have coming up next shadow
20z going up against old sod and like if
you're just looking at the scoreboard
you see if you're like all right ol song
with this he's up 2-0 shadows down oh
and - that's not how it plays out no you
know so we'll see what happens here this
is gonna be an interesting one
especially shadow at this point he could
still have a really big impact on this
group mm-hmm I mean he could still end
up going to and you in the group
like that's not impossible now with
everyone else having a lost I mean if
this is active critical moment right
because if shadow wins here then whole
songs two and one and that means you can
get it go into it too as well we look at
five weeks highs that that's not
possible right now I don't think the
numbers work out does that work up
regardless to see what we got here man
you miss a verse career that new school
battle get ready for the new school
battle next generation tech another
world right here and all Sun going the
bob once again going up against shadows
Claudia yeah and I like the cloudy pic I
mean obviously I like shadow talented
player can use multiple characters this
is Phoenix was getting the work done but
I still prefer him with his Claudio I'd
be like he's like D premier Claudio
player but he got back to Bob for all
time and I said shadow has experience
with matchup I mean I think all son has
experience in this mythology right
mm-hmm
remember agree a lot a lot of really
strong Claudio players out there mole
gold Redman
good crowd - one we got to swap the
names of top that's gonna cap in a
second but this is of course shadow
versus a little sound
boys just kind of swinging mid-range
right now no lows yet
cd1 once again working up roles on here
shuttle back to the wall man look at the
pace just standing there that's what's
really stood out about shadow so far
today yeah and that genocide cut it was
a downtown and yeah just drop it autumns
gonna try to catch the jab duck belly
full Sun get the first round there that
was great I can't be the win underneath
yeah finish the string let's go hung out
with this - pressure all the way to the
wall don't wave this shadow not buckling
shadowy fell asleep during those Raytown
smoking and then finds his spot a the
shoulder no shadow always so solid talk
about spacing that last interaction was
perfect he got hit it - instant running
- that was crazy
clock yeah that was a big bet to go for
the healthy pressure there punch the
starbursts I like the dad makes me up to
block there and again just Danny still
the throat right here dancing the
costume yeah it's a big a big mistake
here no throw break in that situation
hold the confident champ in a row
your wave of shadow trying to counter
poke here all sauce defensive movement
is ridiculous right now it's like 10
seconds of just guarding and olds are
like not that one wave wave wave back -
back to anyway
being squeezed crawls on that with the
bail this is a big change for shadow
damn wall you get the walls left been
too dry not enough to kill you though
and he gets to put the [ __ ] behind all
around game one this is back in Fort
what a complete reversal of fortune oh
man there's one back turn set up right
there that's all it takes
you give up your back to the wall like
that especially when you had control
John glow to you from all Sun good
awareness stay just long that direction
no walls flat nice patient fainted out
the power crush good punch from shadow
gets the blue stuff ready to go
starburst
will he activate old neck locks will
kill by the player this time shadow
ready with the tank
jab jacks I see from the shadows guys
back the wall rage vote now for old sod
nothing
oh I cannot believe that old son didn't
kill it with the combo I cannot believe
it either it that was a definitely
thought the round was over it should
have been over there you know you shadow
was doing the run-through so much
Oh son finally wait a bit of overtook
the duck got the launch but didn't
capitalize with the massive damage combo
I feel like you should be able to kill
there and I'm gonna watch it back and
because of the characters like now he
goes to cosmic I wonder if this is his
strategy running Bob initially and then
going to Casa means turns his rage and
get certain players or certain
characters could be I'm not really sure
but obviously Bob pick didn't work out
there no shadow well prepared for it now
comes Kazumi you know shadows gonna be
prepared for that one as well
but you know similar to how I feel like
shadow with Claude it was his main you
know cos UMI's
all saws being in so this is the match
that I want to see G Corp helipad at
night shadow whip the lead one Joe has
he had the lead in like every match
displayed or what is it great so yeah so
hard to get a read on shadow especially
just stands away he puts himself the
right space he's like I'm gonna stand
here
that's what really stood out to me about
in today especially patients oh really
strong composure mm-hmm also I'm here
trying to push towards those windows I'm
running to pressure
I swear punished
where she can afford the wall I'm trying
to move to pulling the whole guard print
up you and Insadong lets it rip that
time all on complete different story
this first round of the second year yeah
total control for bowls on here these in
your chest Yogi's get ripped off but it
damn walk back the wind they can't they
help out look at the pixel shadow get to
live again oh oh man open the door
22 shout all pin you know so patient in
the wittmers room old sign they bought
that one second yeah shadow though
doesn't seem to have to read on the
timing of old about right now won't
break once again yeah Oh Sonic almost
like it has not been working out this
setting and bunnies jab range here
channel with a Chance here star first
acted on the crap on the head and now
all something to queue up Game three
years easy so easy brings out the Kazumi
and gets it done one to one here what
cool shadow do though Stage Select
Carrick's like I think we go to states
on stage
what states do want Oh
last time with G Corp helipad at night I
think we've seen go to bias it was quite
a bit this goes random gets abandoned
temple out of it you would imagine maybe
you wanted to take away a wall but
actually I haven't yeah I was up for
abandoned temple here at the random slag
but what what could shadow do to kind of
change just break the tempo then all
saman stablish control other than game -
yeah I feel like you know he just let
all Sun I have too much control that
match offensively
yeah and shadow utilizing his defense
was paged before but sometimes you'll
see shadow just go at the offense and
you know if you've been working out when
he does it then thinks a lot of times he
catches the opponent off guard because
he's so defensive that's like way to
think I wasn't expecting any of that so
maybe just try to be a little bit more
offensive at this foot in this set that
running - and shadow just moving
backwards holding guard still yeah and
lift the back leave man when he gets
into that rhythm I love it let me see
the old saw today it's just been
fantastic right he's had the reason all
of his opponents and you know really
strong for him in general yeah shadow
you may look like he had he looked like
he thought he had a real sound timing
but it just never worked out in the last
game
back and forth right here man dick stop
ulsan and like I was talking about the
timing he has it sounds like every
single pony's win against today down to
not cleaned up to kill went the toe kick
down Ford won gonna close it out can we
talk about that focus he's very very
good at picking up one opponent press
ends in time
mmm-hmm yeah now like the first bad boy
he attempted in the set right but it's
pinpoint right actually
it's like elated flash punch knocked
down once opposed me seem tryna step
left there and right now shadows
intercepting him all over man this close
mid-range and low folks
mmm-hmm adding up able to bring the
health back so close stack they poke
poke right now here I like the side
steps to
well Paige is a very low risk oak game
oh that's the first one yeah but it
Connor airborne - no Kabul their shadows
tiny leave not enough to matter now now
rage Motor Vehicles on you know the rate
guys probably gonna end up coming out
there it is
five seconds channels got the lead the
drive spending the time beautiful stuff
from shadow well played awesome clock
place at the very end that was perfectly
home we kept giving a lot of love right
now working out clean walk around sits
in my attorney and the boat checking
those Japs now they're running to
pressure out of old socks there's a step
and that's stuff that we have Lucy
shadow go to a lot of I love all these
lows Camaros on both sides mmm-hmm
supposed to be go back to like forensic
Kazumi all beautifully put forward three
their wall splat - OH other side doesn't
matter man these walls miss cooter the
Holland gets to down hit and then just
like that all song on set point it gets
shadow sit now can 7.0 you know people
complain it cuz we didn't have any good
lows but she's got enough to make you
start wanna dump and they add up
finishes this drink I don't not ready to
sweep at the wall yeah also stepping on
the gas right now
you get three oh you're he's basically
out of the group hold on those shadow
now even on health both play starting to
pull up those homie moves to right
trying to seal each other step in close
range like this rage mode foreshadow old
sod one step away from making to the top
eight right now on running to the Tigers
gonna do it hold on three-oh in the
group gets it done against shadow here
and I'm pretty sure that means that old
sonic locks him in then locks them in to
the top eight later tonight wow that
that changes things and just like we
were saying before that now means you're
gonna have again no Roma knee arson ash
going at each other's throats here to be
they've got a second gotta make it out
of this group that's crazy that is
ridiculous
we are we do have some updates them to
take a look at though and you saw it you
see it on screen now neuroma me are slim
- all one and why it is gonna be greasy
and only one of them can pay yeah that's
crazy
two of those guys are going off near
arson ash one of those guys is going
home I'm not going to the top eight
maybe both
yeah maybe both people one of them is
guaranteed to not go that's crazy
that's crazy check on walls for 2019
finals vain and you knew what you knew
what the expect meant the there's no
randoms here this is a 20 of the top
performance from all year and that says
a lot when you have the players who were
the focal point of the narrative this
year oh yeah and they can't even both
make it the top eight at this term
that's crazy that we still gonna watch
them play you know you know it is that
so much fun and he has never beat him in
tournament like not number wheels he's
gotten those Expos long those long sent
wins right he's got this exhibition way
right but but that's not tournament the
big in especially on the big stage is
right you got imagine some it's a it's a
point of pride for him at this point
right I mean if you were to Vegas that
if you would have said three years ago
that knee would be going to Pakistan the
Train the week before Tekken World Tour
Finals I think most people were to lose
just laugh at you
that says a lot that you force him the
globe tried to get again in pursuit of
getting good enough to be able to take
that we talked about this before it's
been so much focus on Pakistan and arson
ash to me what's what's important is
thinking about what that's gonna give to
low high to the other Korean players to
the other Japanese players the other
players from around the world what
evolution does it force out of them what
are they going to show us here this
weekend that's what we've been waiting
for but man don't forget guys make sure
to check out Quan Quan we've been
supporting the Tekken world to her year
after year they've got this crazy deal
going on with the ages and be obscene
that's the backpack plus the state for
once every nine it's been sick cyber
sale they've been having plus they've
got the drone out there for $49.99 great
introductory stick if you guys just
learn and try to pick up a stick that's
probably one you want to take a look at
because it's got the full-size buttons
and stick there or if you travel a lot
it's very durable by the way I
definitely threw that off my bed on
accident and it totally from what led to
that will let the tasty steam okay yeah
but what do you gotta take a short break
we're gonna continue with our group a
action after this